[Musique]
ok j'ai pris à droite dans une petite
rue je pose semaines mais ça a l'air
cool mais ces gens là viennent de monter
et redescendre déjà je pense qu'il ya
une grosse impasse on lance un sondage
parquet un commentaire je pensais que
c'est l'impasse ou pas j'ai gagné
notamment une impasse il n'y a rien du
tout et c'est joli comme tout vous
réussit la situation je suis en train de
tâter afin d'y puisque c'est vraiment
trop beau ici mais le globe c'est
qu'avec habitude mois et le blesse c'est
que la police dans ce pays aussi bon en
vrai je me suis renseigné sylviane
vraiment tu peux juste 150 euros damende
par exemple en chine tu vas en prison
il décolle pas droit puissent y ait des
câbles plus je peux que reculer pas
avant c'est cool on finit sur un plan de
mes pompes
ça tue sa mère franchement c'est
tellement utile dans les amis j'ai
trouvé l'endroit on voit tous les toits
des maisons traditionnelles ces
magnifiques réhab ceci est de toute
beauté
et franchement je mets une idée parce
qu'on n'a pas trop envie de faire un
coup de drone mâle aux débats mondron de
bâtard ok je suis moqué attention c'est
parti
le drone se situe en zone interdite le
décollage est désactivé qu'on va y
arriver
je suis en train de suivre un petit
circuit en fait un il ya une petite
carte et du coup on passe par plein de
petits trucs comme ça très très beau
très traditionnelle et je veux dire
c'est encore 600 fois jusqu'à ce que ce
sens dans une zone où je puisse faire du
drone voilà je suis frustré auction
traditionnel kraft expérience center
voilà si vous voulez vous kraft et une
coiffe du beauf tout c'est la toile ils
font les porte à ma taille et sont
sympas ils ont pensé à moi je dépasse
les trucs ces minuscules frodon a pris
sa retraite ici mais je me suis rendu à
l'atelier graff ya pas de quoi bouffer
tout en fait c'est juste une technique
font encore et où en fait il a fui avec
leurs doigts pour mettre de la feuille
d'or sur leurs tissus
regardez voilà mes amis je viens de
sortir de cet endroit c'était super beau
y avait plein de trucs fait main et qui
utilise la technique de rejoindre vous
parler et j'ai craqué j'achète un cadre
qui exclut un truc et c'est sacré donc j
ai pas droit pour des photos du coup je
vais un peu par mois j'ai l'impression
que tout est sacré du genre ça un banc
un simple banque et j'ai demandé c'était
sacré ou si je peux m'asseoir dessus
c'était le quartier traditionnel et en
fait c'est carrément habité ya plein de
pancartes je suis de faire leur gueule
et touristes via le wifi un pour dire
des amis qui la connaissaient bien et
leur demander de venir dans ce pays les
amis je me trouve actuellement devant un
télésiège pour quoi faire pour rejoindre
la namsa tower qui est tous là haut on
peut la voir là elle dépasse totalement
pour les gens courageux il ya un chemin
à pied tous ces gens sont comme nous ils
n'ont pas de courage et pas de muscles
accessoirement
[Musique]
à
c'est de toute beauté ban en écoutant
absolument génial et c'est toulalan peut
aller au fond c'est ça par contre j'ai
peur d'être dans on est serein on y va
ou pas pression du manic et voilà la vue
d'en haut de la tour
voilà heureusement que j'ai le courage
de monter à la tour parce que [ __ ]
vrai que la vue ou fut excellent c'est
faux je sais vous croirait jamais mais
j'aurais vrai on peut pas y aller en
fait c'est un restaurant au deuxième
trou sinon j'avais pas peur je suis
courageux ok j'ai trouvé la meilleure
attraction à l'endroit on a réussi à
aller dans la tourmente inventé rien
fait je vais prendre en photo avec la
table mon choix oui ok posté à la ligne
on est bien et elle est parfaite
restez l'entraînement maintenant on fait
la vraie attention résultat des courses
nul à chier
excellent les amis les tours de prendre
notre revanche sur ces où loge plus pas
interdit de faire du drone bad things
parce qu'à séoul il ya un parc adro ça
fait 27 mille mètres carrés de mon gars
je sort l'artillerie lourde
[Musique]
les amis jour 2 aujourd'hui on va
commencer la journée avec un peu de
shopping
je vous ferai un petit hall après et
après sa fiesta loca baby pourquoi pas
ce que je vais me faire mon deuxième
tatouages
en fait quand je suis allé en colombie
rejoindre mon frère et je me suis fait
le crabe ici présent je me suis dit que
dans tous les pays où gérer j'aimerais
me faire un tatouage du coup aujourd'hui
j'aime faire mon tatouage coréen et j'ai
repéré un tatouage qui s'appelle une
cote à thouars qui a un style un peu
kawai rigolo il ya pas mal de points sur
tatouage c'est très très beau show j'ai
hâte de découvrir ça mais avant
attention shopping je gagne le droit et
je vous fais roule en mode hors accord
très très mal fait ben voila je reviens
du shopping j'ai acheté un petit pull de
hipsters voilà on dirait mon frère et
avec ceux ci un superbe manteau beige
les filles alors sûr je vous conseille
parce qu'il est belge et ce à un parfait
mix entre le blanc et le noir
j'ai aussi acheté des petites boucles
d'oreilles noah parce que c'est flou à
ok are you mind qui est tombé zut
après ce moment les ans qu'est ce qu'on
va faire on va aller visiter enfin
visité j'ai déjà fait quand j'étais venu
en mars mais on va aller en ondes dès le
quartier que je kiffe au corps et son
quartier préféré aller on attend quoi
les amis bienvenue à hong décès le
quartier où il ya le plus de jeunes et
le plus de petites boutiques et de petit
commerce reçoit un peu au japon
et c'est là où j'étais venu l'année
dernière en mars du coup c'est pas la
dernière
arrêté dans les détails il ya plein de
gens par les petites boutiques un peu
hipsters de où ces gens des jeunes
designers qu'ont fait les fringues et
pas mal de petits restos enfin c'est
vraiment pour moi le meilleur quartier
tout bien encore et rené ont dette en
monnaie
[Musique]
et
voilà
miam
mon gars
m
je tape de la main sur la table parce
que dans trois ans et demi c'est l'heure
du tatouage et 3 parce que je sais moi
même pas à quoi il va ressembler encore
je le serai que quand on sera au salon
tu vas faire 10 cm à l'ombre et de la 3g
comme ton saisie voilà je préfère le
blagueur personnes comprend bien
problème est bon donc le moment est venu
de tester ce qui s'apparente est des
boucles d'oreilles
oh mon dieu ça y est la deuxième jour
plus galérer pour la droite je pense
parce que je suis gaucher
d'ailleurs j'y arriverais authentic seul
le bloc d'un mec qui essaie de les faire
sinon le chaque seconde qui passe est un
risque supplémentaire sur lequel je vais
prendre un pouce rouge au cerveau je
suis très content parce qu'ils sont tout
petits comme pouvez constater j'ai des
oreilles demain c'est mon défaut mais
j'entends bien les amis je viens
d'arriver au savon de bogota tout et
c'est très très très très bon c'est
magique
le jet lag est toujours présent il ya
peut-être moyen je m'endors c'est ce que
je dis mais vrai j'aurais tellement mal
que j'ai pire bien écrit dessine même
sur des cailloux et à tout prix qui m'a
dit que je veux
il a même crois jamais s'est rendormi
dans le tatouage m'a dit que c'est plus
embêtant dans ta poche
c'est simple pour laval mais c'est
vraiment arrivé très très beau bon là ça
bave c'est dégueu mais c'est donc sa
cicatrice quoi et je vais rentrer faire
un énorme d'autour de retour à la
chambre d'hôtel mais qu'elle est belle
qu'elle est belle cette petite chouette
dans sagan et je suis pas heureux il a
fait du super boulot en plus on a pu
échanger avec lui sur la corée voilà lui
qui est un vrai corps est un peu dingue
grande parce que ici si vous le savez
pas les tatouages c'est illégal et en
plus lui il est vraiment à tous et bien
comme vous avez pu voir sur le visage
etc
et c'est pas du tout admis en fait ici
d'être tattoo est très mal vu du succès
en beauté les goûts du regard des autres
les gens voient comment on s'en fout des
mêmes tant mieux même si au moins ils
m'approche pas aller base la vie lui ça
où tu vas c'est la fin de ce blog
c'était pas aimer l'eau ça vous a plu
un petit génie plus énergique et puis je
vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo c'est elle ou trop la plus blasés
de la chaîne youtube
je parle pas fort dirais que là ma mère
dans la pièce d'à côté et qui aime bien
rigoler je parle trop fort moi je manque
ce thème